there's a kind of certain look to Gordon
of that could be interpreted as
nervousness that was an incorrect
interpretation yes okay so there's a uh
what do you interpret as nervous
Behavior
well this is uh part of me is trolling
but
sometimes on the surface confident
Behavior can look like uh
almost like anger
and there's a
Gordon's face had a like a vulnerability
to it almost like uh when you go to
judge confidence don't look at the face
look at the extremities of the body yeah
that's where the truth comes out you see
it in body language and the further from
the face and cheers the more honest the
body becomes
look at the feet and the hands
well there were I mean that's when you
see if people are nervous or not he was
very relaxed uh in the extremities
that's true see you look more confident
in this in this than anything what what
are you thinking about what I what uh
what's going through your head here
all right this is the same stuff are you
are you intimidated by the the two Meat
Heads one in a suit and tie or are you
not thinking about that at all I know
now for me it's just about okay what's
the most efficient positive Victory
against this particular opponent
it's just okay I've done my job I've
taken them through a uh an extensive
fight camp that prepared them for every
conceivable situation that they're in uh
I've run an efficient warm-up their body
temperature is perfect the elasticity
the muscles is perfect
um
my main role when I corner
is I avoid what most people do when they
Corner which is to be a cheerleader most
cornermen they're not cornermen they're
cheerleaders they're there to express
some kind of emotional support to their
training partners and or their student
s sometimes they're even worse than
cheerleaders they express their own
emotional fears
as the match goes on
um
I always believe that 99.5 percent of
the job of the trainer is done the coach
is done
when the athlete steps their foot on the
mat
at that point
you shouldn't need me at all everything
I needed to tell you should have been
not just told you but imprinted into you
remember this fifteen thousand people in
that crowd for half of the match you're
not going to hear a word that I can say
there's too much noise but you'll hear
my voice inside your head
because you've heard it so many times
over the last 14 weeks you're sick of
hearing it at that point
in their program know what to do
um
so I'm I'm usually
pretty confident I'm also very confident
that even in worst case scenarios they
can have effective Solutions because
they train those worst case scenarios
every single day in the gym
and so in part you're there to have a
front row seat
to analyze what happened so you can take
that to the next match the biggest
danger in athlete faces is tunnel vision
sometimes they will
Hit Upon A Certain move or strategy and
just say I'm going to go with this when
there's much easier Alternatives but
because they're so focused on the
alternative they've chosen they get this
tunnel vision and just focus only on
that the most constructive thing the
corner man can do is alert them to the
presence of time which is very important
in ADCC match because they're all the
scoring is structured by time and to
alleviate problems associated with
tunnel vision that okay you're doing
this
but if you just did this it'll be so
much easier so that's the main goal